we found something a chance maybe
that I was to use the students again so
that's gonna use them to bring everyone
back just like that
yeah just like that
ten days we have a chance to take it all
back
about how much we lost
it's about how much we have left
who hasn't been in space
you better not throw up on my ship we
are getting ball team yeah
I like this one Oh God what's up
regular-sized man heroes it's an
old-fashioned emotion some visionary
from genius ensuring freedom around the
globe a symbol to the nation a hero to
the world
shining out across the Stars
I look around at us you know what I see
a bunch of a-holes possibility
you think you know how the world works
the wound
is changing
[Music]
need
heroes
[Applause]
I'll very strength
[Music]
in whites challenge
Challenge insights contract
culture
Brees catastrophe
the thing isn't beautiful because it
lasts
[Music]
we're in the anger
before we're done
we still have one promise to keep
as you can't protect the Earth it can be
damn sure we'll avenge it
[Music]
whatever it takes
[Applause]
hi everyone its charlie we only got ten
days to go before Avengers end game gets
here they're dropping all kinds of
trailers we got a couple of new scenes
and a couple really big montages so
let's break it down there's a new round
of that imax ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave an Avengers comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this because we are getting really
close to the film coming out if you do
have a chance to see it early please do
not post spoilers on the videos here
when we're all just talking about
trailer footage and speculating about
what's going on we start with new
voiceover from Black Widow it sounds
like maybe when she's gone to Tokyo to
try and pick Hawkeye Ronin up to get him
to come back to the team after whatever
a short time jump they have during the
movie there's still a lot of question
about when some of these scenes happen
so we're just kind of using black widows
hair to chart the timeline she says we
think we found something a chance that's
probably the quantum stuff that's going
on later in the film when they're
wearing those white quantum shoes she's
probably referring to whatever that plan
winds up being there's a little more
footage from that opening scene we got
last week with them talking to Captain
Marvel and looking at that readout of
Thanos using the Infinity Gauntlet again
making that first plan to try and just
go get him like we'll just do this right
at the beginning of the movie it'll
totally work great what could possibly
go wrong
you see the Benatar taking off into
orbit it's either from early in the film
from this scene here that we keep seeing
where it's from later in the film when
we see Hawkeye and Black Widow on the
back because there's a shot of Hawkeye
and Black Widow on the benitar that
looks like it's happening during a
totally different part of the movie than
this early scene with them on the
benitar there's a little bit of new
Captain America voice over where he says
we've got a chance to take it all back
obviously talking about all the stuff
that they knows snap from them while
Black Widow works the punching bag in a
scene that looks just like the Captain
America post-credit scene from the first
Captain America film when Nick Fury was
showing up to recruit him to join the
Avengers and he was just working the
punching bag to death Black Widow much
later in the film with her red hair
after a bigger time jump over seeing
whatever work they're doing in the
Avengers base on whatever this quantum
realm plan is I think this is all tied
to what they're doing with those white
suits the fact that some of the
characters look older visibly like Iron
Man during some shots in the fact that
black widows hair gets really red just
makes it seem like at some point in the
film there is a really big time jump
there's a shot-up Ironman in his new
mark 85 armor and Hawkeye inside the
Avengers base during a completely
different scene getting ready for
something iron man puts his helm on and
brings up an energy shield so they're
probably messing with something that's
really dangerous there's a new shot of
Captain Marvel outside the Avengers base
at night it's hard to tell when this is
happening during the film if it's early
or if it's happening a little bit later
then there's the tag from that early
scene that they keep showing off with
rocket and everyone on the back during
the first time they go back to get
Thanos who here has not been into space
Captain America a black widow war
machine all sheepishly raised their
hands you better not throw up on my ship
there's a brand new shot of Captain
Marvel flying in the same big battle
scene that we saw Iron Man Thor in
Captain America fighting Thanos in which
seems like it's happening much later in
the film but if you look at the
background of this Captain Marvel shot
all the debris on the ground is the
exact same is the debris behind Iron Man
here so it's confirmed that she's there
it also looks like rocket and war
machine are there too
this is probably like a bunch of other
people in the background that we just
can't see based on the way they're
cutting these trailers it could be the
Avengers base it just seems like there's
a building that's been blown up around
them and then there's this other shot of
rocket and war machine inside the
Avengers base while it looks like it's
being blown up there's a new scene of
Iron Man talking to Captain America in
their civilian clothes but it looks like
it's happening much later in the film
with him asking we're gonna get the rest
of the team back together right like
he's trying to make sure that
everybody's in on whatever this new plan
is that seems like it's tied to these
white quantum realms suits that they use
that kind of makes it seem like they
have a couple attempts early in the film
that are unsuccessful and then they
really get down and kind of go their
separate ways for a brief period so
maybe they do split up for a little bit
during the film there's a really badass
new scene of Iron Man using his new
weapons that are part of the new mark 85
armor during this same big fan OHS fight
that we keep seeing that's happening
later in the film there's a new shot of
Captain America from that same battle in
his comic book scale armor all from the
same group of scenes the same part of
the film there's a new shot of rocket in
his comic-book uniform on the underside
of something that looks like Hank Pym
and ant-man's quantum technology this
just looks like it's part of whatever
rig they construct as part of the reason
why they're wearing these white quantum
suits any time rocket is wearing his
blue comic-book uniform it also seems
like it's happening much later in the
film too this
brand-new funny scene of roadies
surprising ant-man outside the Avengers
base after ant-man's arrived in his van
screaming to get in hey normal-sized man
just sort of making fun of him because
of the last big fight they had during
Civil War when he was giant man there's
a brand new scene of Hawkeye Ronan in
the Avengers base with rocket while he's
wearing his blue comic book costume in a
war machine looking like [ __ ] is getting
ready to go down then there's the same
shot of Captain America and everyone in
their quantum suits
whatever it takes putting their hands in
the center then there's a new shot of
Santos's mothership the sanctuary -
emerging from what looks like some sort
of space nebula it's hard to tell what's
going on but it does look like because
the background here is kind of purple
that this is still happening in outer
space then they have a really big
highlight reel of all the Marvel movies
from phase 1 phase 2 and phase 3 which
is just a montage of all the characters
really big moments up to this point
because the movies coming out next week
I do think there'll be a couple more TV
spots but I don't expect any really big
trailers or anything like that but if
there's anything really cool or really
funny that they post I'll totally make a
video about it but if you remember the
videos that I did for infinity war when
it came out last year I did my review
videos post credits Easter eggs all that
stuff I'll do the same videos for
Avengers end game starting next week
when it starts to come out if I do get a
chance to see it early then I will post
a non-spoilery review so no worries I
won't do any spoiler stuff before the
movie actually comes out but the best
advice that I could give you if you're
worried about spoilers next week just go
see the movie as early as you possibly
can go see it Thursday night if that's
possible and if you can't do that try
and go see it on Friday I'm not planning
on doing any big box office predictions
or anything like that but I do think
that this movie will beat avatars record
definitely making more than two billion
dollars easily but beyond that we'll see
two point five two point six
it'll be really easy to tell within the
first week or so about how much money
it's gonna make and make no mistake it
is gonna earn all the money it is gonna
be crazy so everybody just get really
excited it's gonna be awesome next week
Game of Thrones is back and I'm doing
videos for that so I'll link that at the
end of this but congratulations to the
winner from my last big Marvel giveaway
Willy bands please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details while you wait for everything
click here for my brand new Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 2 trailer video
and click here
for my last big Avengers endgame trailer
Easter Egg video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome you just
got to make it one more week for endgame
[Music]